[Musique]
al'approche de la journée mondiale sans
tabac les élèves du collège plateau
goyaves à saint louis se sont prêtés ce
mardi 3 mai à un petit exercice réalisé
un spot pour une campagne de prévention
un projet éducatif et solidaire qui
permet aux jeunes d'en découvrir plus
sur la production audiovisuelle ce
collage équipé d'un studio médias
financés par le département et ses
studios médias et bien aux provocations
justement de donner la parole aux élèves
de les rendre acteurs de ce qui les
préoccupe au quotidien qu'ils
s'approprient cet outil pourrait
justement partagé avec
les communautés les autres collèges se
passe dans l'établissement et ça c'est
exactement ce qu'un enfant se produira
aujourd'hui les marmailles ont accepté
dans un délai extrêmement court de
répondre à la sollicitation de saoû me
sentais un diction en outre-mer qui a
sollicité le département justement pour
mettre en place le spot il est rond
répondu favorablement et on ne peut que
les féliciter sur la performance qu'ils
ont et qu'ils sont en train de faire une
initiative portée par l'association sao
mai soutenu par le département qui
s'inscrit dans le prolongement de
l'apprentissage des collégiens alors on
a eu une proposition de madame marthe
acquis et la terrisse de communication
de sao mai donc elle nous a parlé un
petit peu du projet
rapidement j'ai discuté un petit peu
avec les élèves du club théâtre qui
était d'accord bien portant et
et là associés aussi les élèves du club
médias donc on s'est retrouvé là
discuter des textes des scénarios on les
a retravaillé réécrit et aujourd'hui on
se retrouve pour monde mettre tout ça un
petit peu en place faire les premières
prises de vue c'est eux qui s'occupent
de du film des prises de vue des micros
et du montage actions malgré le trac les
jeunes ont pu s'attaquer au vif du sujet
le tournage du spot grâce à l'équipement
mise à disposition par le département
une expérience enrichissante synonyme de
challenge à relever pour les adolescents
donc nous dans le collège on fait comme
un petit reportage ont ensuite on publie
sur le journal du collège
et on va faire des petits reportages un
peu partout on a parlé un peu hier on a
fait quelques repérages pour aller les
emplacements etc et aujourd'hui du coup
ben on place un peu haut niveau comme on
avait fait les repérages bien et du coup
on a pu trouver c'est un camion de
travail la suisse est sympa ce petit
groupe là c'est un atelier théâtre moi
j'irai quelle difficulté ça a été sur le
les premières copies du des différents
textes parce que ça correspondait pas
avec
le langage des jeunes d'aujourd'hui qui
ont l'adulent malheureux adapter les
textes moi je pense qu'on travaille me
sous l'effet de la pression et du stress
travail plus rapidement et après leur à
ce que ça donne après sept journées de
tournage les élèves entameront la
dernière phase du travail le montage de
leurs films il sera ensuite mise en
avant à l'occasion de la journée sans
tabac qui se tiendra le 31 mai prochain
[Musique]